this video is sponsored by skillshare
hello if you stumbled over here from
this side of my channel you are now in
the forbidden zone this is where i talk
about books if that bores you then i
have a link in the description that will
provide hours and hours of free
entertainment just go ahead click on the
link check it out so anyways
books what are they why do we like what
what's what's going on with them why is
it that so many of us loved reading as a
kid yet
none of us do some of us do but i feel
like i'm i'm special so what is what's
the deal with that how did that come
about this video is about the education
system specifically how we enforce
harmful reading habits in children even
more specifically i'm talking about the
united states because then i'm speaking
from personal experience so here's why
us bookworms don't read jack [ __ ]
anymore i want to focus specifically on
a program that was very
detrimental to my own education
accelerated reader ar for short while
not everyone experienced ar i feel like
there was always some kind of oppressive
force especially in elementary school
and middle school but before we continue
a word from our sponsor skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity with skillshare i've enjoyed
skillshare for a while now i've done
several sponsored videos with them
they've always been excellent to work
with i've talked about this specific
course before but i think it's worth
mentioning again because i got a lot of
good stuff from it the writer's toolkit
six steps to a successful writing habit
by simon van boy building a good writing
routine is very important and i think
that people can take very different
routes towards doing that you can do it
in bite size videos or watch the full
course it's curated specifically for
learning meaning there are no ads
they're always launching new premium
classes so you can stay focused
skillshare now offers classes in spanish
french portuguese and german first
thousand people to click on the link in
the description get skillshare for free
for one month so check it out learn
something new thank you skillshare back
to the video accelerated reader what is
it and how is its influence bad ar is
supposed to be a system that motivates
kids to read more it's also very
lucrative for its company renaissance so
here's how it works you're a kid you're
in second grade you're picking your nose
and throwing curtains at john oliver i
don't know why that's the first time i
thought of your teacher makes you take a
very short test that basically
determines what you get to read now i'm
not going to get exactly into the
details of what the test decides you can
read but it basically determines based
on your comprehension yada yada this is
kind of the grade level you're at you
may be a few grades higher you may be a
few grades lower but you're basically
stuck to this range art does not
consider content a very dark and serious
book written with a very simple style
may be a third or fourth grade level and
so now we have third or fourth graders
trying to read this book and not really
coming away with anything because the
content is too far beyond them or
messing them the [ __ ] up you know let's
get back to our classroom setting you
have taken this start it's called the
star test i don't know what what that
stands but wait you can't read any old
books in there you have to read the one
specifically brought into this ar system
weird example i wanted to read jules
verne from the earth to the moon guess
what that wasn't in the system i can't
read that i'm not going to waste time
reading that and the reason why not all
of these books can be in the system is
because you have to take a quiz so you
sit down you take a quiz some quizzes
are 10 questions some quizzes are 20
questions depending on the book you read
moby dick what kind of questions do you
think the quiz asks maybe it wants you
to consider the the meaning of the text
in the whales and how how ahabs uh no
it's about comprehension of information
from a very young age this system is
teaching kids to gather basic
information from a text and then take
these quizzes and let me be honest most
kids are not reading these books
especially if they are classics and
information can be easily acquired from
spark notes i was a little goody two
shoes okay like i actually read the
books which made my life hell you take
these quizzes you get certain points
from the quizzes let's say you want to
read a book like moby dick there may be
more points for reading that book but
let's say you do poorly on the test
you're not getting all those one maybe
you're getting half of those points
maybe you're not even succeeding at the
test because that book is really dense
and there's a lot of information that
maybe goes over your head maybe i'm
talking about a specific traumatic
moment from my past i don't know either
way you're [ __ ] not only are you
frustrated and angry but now you are
concerned about the types of books
you're allowed to read are not allowed
to read why would you read these new
releases if they're not in the ar system
i would read books that i didn't want to
read just so that i could fulfill the
point quota that i had to fulfill not
every school uses a system of punishment
some schools use a system of reward now
i think that's better it's not perfect
though let's say you hit your quota of
points because you've read this many
books and passed this many quizzes you
get all these points now you get a
i don't know a trip to the zoo it's
still treating reading as a chore that
you do in order to get a reward now i'll
get back on that later every class i had
that used accelerated reader it was
factored into our grade that's not
that's not cool okay you're already
reading tons of books for class writing
book reports now in the time you
actually get to read you're focusing on
remembering basic facts from the books
and making sure that the book is
actually available for you to read and
that it has enough points for you to
fill your point quota before the end of
the quarter or semester or whatever he
just talking about this getting me into
a like a sweaty panic this is this was
like more stressful than college i swear
to god on to the next point i was in a
higher reading range i was just that kid
you know obnoxious basically um because
of that there were a lot of books that i
simply i definitely wasn't encouraged to
read those books and for people in the
lower range they weren't encouraged to
read books of a higher range and i'm not
saying those books were like darker more
disturbing uh have more complex themes
no they were just had longer sentences
like they just had more complex language
we should not be discouraging kids from
trying to read outside of their range i
mean that's how they accelerate their
reading growth everything about this
system was
agonizing it made my joy of reading that
i had inherently it turned it into
another chore and this brings me to my
final and i think most important point
that i really want to hammer home the
biggest issue with accelerated reader
and any program that treats reading as a
system of reward or punishment when when
reading is looked as not a reward in
itself we have we've lost um i think so
many of us have a love of reading as
kids that we do not revisit until much
later until school is way in the past
that we start to go okay let's revisit
reading you know because we have a
thirst for information for stories for
that sense of fun you know there has to
be a better way to encourage kids to
read for their own benefit for the sake
of reading itself you know i think
that's also another reason why a lot of
adults are primarily interested in
non-fiction they feel kind of like
guilty maybe reading fiction they don't
feel like it's worthwhile it's not worth
their time because it's not like
watching tv which can just be fun
reading a book has to be gathering
information it has to be like homework
you can't just read a book and have fun
which is one of the best things about
life okay i just want to remind people
of the kind of brainwashing that a lot
of us have been through and don't beat
yourself up about the fact that
sometimes the idea of picking up a book
and reading it can feel like a chore the
problem is you feel like you should be
reading not that you want to be reading
and you feel like you should be reading
things that you should be reading like
important works no [ __ ] it read whatever
you want pick up captain underpants
enjoy go for what you love and remember
that sense of of childlike wonder when
you pick up a book it doesn't have to be
the way it is and it's really sad and
stupid that it is but please let me know
about whatever
stupid system your school used to
enforce your destructive reading habits
because this whole
research topic made me think of that and
i i would like to link a cert a specific
uh article or blog that uh highlighted a
lot of the problems in ar that reminded
me of of a lot of this and um are i
think it's really worth reading anyways
thanks for watching keep reading bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you